in recent times many technology
companies especially those that
specialize in database systems have been
part of high-profile acquisitions
running up to the hundreds of millions
of dollars clue
ding-ding-ding-ding you should be
thinking of specific companies right now
right account for the value of such
companies what companies we take you to
big examples Instagram number one who
boredom Facebook and they're also an
example Yahoo bought someone recently
heard they bike tumbler okay
BAM okay there you go three concrete
examples why is Facebook valuable why is
Facebook value what bid I've got
databases why are they valuable who are
they valuable to advertisers bingo right
if you want to put out an ad on Google
right all you can say is well if they
search for these things then pull up
this app put a Facebook if you want to
advertise you can say I would advertise
to people who are 26 years old who live
in this county and they only watch these
TV shows right
that's how specific you can be more
specific than that okay so that
granularity comes from this massive
crazy database to Facebook ads that's
why they valuable okay that's Facebook
what about say Instagram why are they
valuable why is Instagram penguin
they don't have advertising at all did
you notice that at least not yet
why are they valuable okay what kind of
information do they provide location
does massive pool of photos hundreds of
millions of them right all the time and
hashtags are like try to think of
they're attached to users and you've
also as massive user base right so if
your Facebook you want to access that
set of users you can't just get them
from you can say hey could you please
give us that database
you got a bio all right that's the way
you do it so there's a tumblr works the
same way they've got a massive bunch of
users it's not through advertising and
lastly as a third point are we set
advertisers we said information about
them we said a user base its loyal
fourthly I would say you know companies
like Facebook and Instagram they often
require users did you notice this to
relinquish copyright over
their intellectual property right you
sign up for Facebook all your photos are
theirs right they can sell them and do
whatever they want them okay and
everyone didn't read their terms and
conditions today like really they earn
my furnace yeah they totally earn your
photos okay so that's really valuable
right it's a data based company but the
Dada that got tremendously valuable
right